I've got a few minutes after these very
stimulating and exciting and
inspirational presentations and
discussions to suggest that we think
about accessibility as we're thinking
about technology and teaching and
learning
when Peter Salovey became the president
of Yale he set forth a vision for the
university and he wants yell to be an
innovative Yale and I think we're seeing
evidence of that today two other goals
that he said are very dear and central
to the mission of the CTL to be the
research university most committed to
teaching and learning and to offer a
Yale education to an even more diverse
student body when he talks about this
mission this this second goal he talks
about an accessible Yale that opens its
doors based on individuals and
accomplishments potential and ability
what I'd like to ask is when we think
about this goal of diversity and our
commitment to diversity what is it that
we think about typically we tend to
think diversity means opening the doors
to students of racial ethnic maybe
socio-economic groups who have been
underrepresented at a place like Yale in
the past there are other groups that we
tend not to think about when we took
when we think about diversity another
question accessible when Peter salivate
uses this word accessible he's talking
about financial accessibility he wants
to make sure that anybody who is
qualified can access Yale regardless of
their financial means but what else
might we mean by accessible the
population that I'm suggesting that we
think about in terms of accessibility
and diversity are our students with
disabilities
so you might not realize this but
Americans
disabilities is one of the largest
minority populations in the u.s. there
are 57 million Americans with
disabilities which is roughly equal to
the number of Americans of Hispanic
Latino or Spanish origin descent
heritage and that makes up 19% of the
u.s. population in terms of the
population in among undergraduate
students 11% of undergraduate students
nationally as well as here at Yale
reported having at least one disability
but that number probably is undercounts
the total number of students who have a
disability here's an interesting
statistic of all the students who in
their K through 12 educational
environment received some type of
support from their schools only 1/3 of
those actually register when they go to
college with the office that is supposed
to support students with disabilities so
this suggests that of these 11% of
undergraduates who raise their hand and
self-identify as having a disability the
number is probably much larger in some
cases the student don't even realize
that they have a disability the largest
majority of these students have what we
might call invisible the disabilities so
when we tend to think about disability
we imagine a student who's blind and has
a guide dog or we imagine somebody in a
wheelchair but actually the most common
disabilities are largely invisible
interesting story I've had the
opportunity to speak with a number of
Yale faculty over the years about
students with disabilities and often
times I've heard them say you know I've
been teaching at Yale for 20 years I
don't think I've ever had a student in
my class with a disability and I told
them I'm sure that you have you just
weren't aware of it Yale students for
obvious reasons are
to raise their hands and self-identify
and ask for extra help of the students
who do report disabilities 36 percent of
them have learning disabilities
including dyslexia 26% have a DD ADHD
13% have mental illness or dealing with
certain psychological challenges and all
the other disabilities which are the
ones that we tend to think about the
most together make up 25% so this
graphic can can actually it actually
explains a bit why we're not thinking
about disabilities among our students
because we're not necessarily we can't
recognize the students who have
disabilities so technology it's been a
real boon for students with disabilities
it's it is allowing them more and more
to be independent and to rely less on
special accommodations that are provided
by an office devoted to that so some
examples for students with motor
disabilities and this can include
somebody who broke her arm as well as
somebody who uses wheelchair somebody
with with a spinal cord injury who might
not be able to use their hands there are
special keyboards that make it easier
for them to keep up with writing
assignments they're also new and
increasingly good speech-to-text
technology so rather than the student
typing a paper there was actually a law
student here who wrote and submitted his
entire thesis using this technology
where he trained a computer program to
understand his voice so that he could
dictate and correct not using his hands
at all it's pretty amazing
for students that have auditory
disabilities captioning and transcripts
are just critical as more and more
faculty are using media in their
teaching and learning we also have the
service for for students who have
hearing difficulties there can be live
captioning going on during a lecture
we have a service that's available you
might not be aware of it if you're
teaching in the classroom and you see a
student with a laptop open what what we
can do is there will be somebody it's
basically like a court reporter who is
is doing a live transcription of your
lecture and that's being sent through
Wireless to the students laptop so the
student can watch and read and follow
your lecture even if they're not sitting
close enough to lip-read or they they
can't hear for for another reason one
last example when I talked about speech
to text there's also text-to-speech
technology so a student who can't read
by looking at the text increasingly use
technology that can look at the text for
the student and actually translate it
into into sound and one thing I'll point
out here that that it is actually very
illuminating this technology was first
developed for students with visual
disabilities somebody who needs who
can't see the text but can listen to it
what's really interesting is that the
technologies technology that was
developed for one population actually is
very useful for another population and
and this is students with dyslexia who
learn much better if they can hear
something rather than only read it or
can hear it at the same time that
they're eating it so this is an example
of the idea of universal design the idea
is that if you can if we can find a way
to create an access for one population
that that access point might actually be
beneficial to populations you didn't
even anticipate this is the classic
example if I asked for a show of hands
of how many of you have ever pushed a
baby stroller down the sidewalk or
rolled your luggage cart down the
sidewalk or taking a bicycle on the
sidewalk how many of you have ax
looked for the ramp so that it made your
life much easier I see lots of hands of
course these ramps were not designed to
make it easier for you to roll your
luggage maybe at the airport that's the
case but typically these ramps were
designed to help people who use
wheelchairs but this technology this
design that that was meant to meet the
needs of one particular population
actually makes life a lot easier for
everybody so this is the goal when we
think about how can we make our courses
most accessible can we find the
educational equivalents of these curb
cuts so that we are thinking proactively
about the needs of a particular
population in our course but we're
actually making our course more
accessible to everybody
so one of the challenges were technology
even though it can offer a lot of
support it can also introduce obstacles
and this is why whenever we choose a
technology and whenever our students
become very dependent on a technology we
need to be very thoughtful and
deliberate in the technologies that that
we use we can unwittingly
by selecting a certain technology make
our make a learning experience
inaccessible to some of our students a
good example we have the teal classroom
up on hill house and it's designed to
promote active learning
we had an instructor a couple of years
ago who was following all the best
practices for how to lead an active
classroom and discussion based in small
groups what she didn't anticipate was
that a deaf student enrolled in the
course and this duct student was very
very good at lip-reading
but in a discussion based classroom when
everybody is talking at the same time
and when the professor is walking around
the room and talking the student had no
idea who to look at and she could not
keep up so she actually went to the
professor and said I really want to
take this class but the way that you've
designed in this active learning is
making it inaccessible to me the
professor was horrified she was trying
to do all the right things and she had
never really thought oh what if I have a
deaf student in my class so the
challenge is trying to think proactively
to imagine the diversity of students who
might enroll in your class and rather
than be in the position that this
professor was in was after doing months
of planning and rolling it out all of a
sudden having to rethink everything on
the spot quickly can we be more
proactive and more deliberate and
thoughtful about the way we design our
classes so that we're not discriminating
against certain students and we are
providing as many as many curb cuts as
possible so it's just a question if
anybody most people here are using the
learning management system any any
thoughts on what might be the most
common accessibility issue we have in
canvas
any yeah I guess is one thing I'll
mention so we just we just completed
this transition to canvas it was painful
it took a lot of effort from everybody
but one of the main reasons we did it
was because our old system classes b2
was very very bad at being accessible to
people who use a screen reader canvas is
excellent to that okay I'll give you the
answer inaccessible PDF files so faculty
are increasingly sharing readings with
their students by scanning a textbook or
an article and uploading a PDF file into
canvas problem is if you don't create
the PDF in the right way a student who's
dyslexic and using a screen reader or a
student who has visual impairment will
not be able to access that so there's a
lot that we debt that we're still
learning there's a lot that we don't
know that we're doing that is making it
more difficult for students so I'm very
happy that this month in fact on
Wednesday we are
getting off a new series through the CTL
where we're going to be thinking about
issues issues of accessibility in course
design and in the use of technology and
there is a handout on the table read out
here that highlights a whole series of
events going on throughout the month of
October October is National Disability
Awareness Month seven of those are
actually offered by the CTL and they're
highlighted here so I invite you to to
come to any that you can we hope to
continue the series beyond October and
we look forward to working with you
thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]